aí eu vou falar sobre um projeto chamado
inventário e é o verdadeiro projeto de
inovação social
se eu perder o dia tenho mais chance ao
primeiro risco de o corro é de passar a
imagem que eu considero uma pessoa
altruísta e eu acho que eu explicou que
sempre quis falar assim de coisas de
inovação social que nós falamos com
algum envolvimento é uma paixão
eu cada vez acredito mais que por trás
destas idéias que nós precisamos ao
longo de anos e acho que é possível ao
longo do ano está menor nunca o
abandonou com menor necessidade nossa
nos apaziguar mãos é uma vira lata
protetora muito mais que qualquer outro
mesmo eu sou realmente sobre a tratar em
um curso profissional muito muito linear
sou médica de 97 no teatro desde 2005 só
dava euro estão a trabalhar neste
hospital do texto 2006 e 2007 comecei a
ficar muito as crianças e jovens
configurações desenvolver - não sei se
irei votar não posso dizer com certeza
mas nesta fase
sinto que há sim mas preciso também sem
retorno
tal como muitos muitos de nós eu sendo
diariamente no lugar de apontadores
porque não sei onde estou eu posso
realmente apontar o que não funciona ou
então por que segurar uma caneta que
literalmente a ponta dos dedos
os dois nas uma certa inquietação ea
inquietação quanto persiste gera idéias
as idéias funcionarem são como asas nem
fazendo voar
se não funcionam como cordas perto uns
tanto elas têm que funcionar
claro que origem deste projeto vale
tarde está na óbvia ensinado o projeto
deles a origem da persistência pode
estar nessa inquietação que estou a
falar das muitas horas assegurar essa
caneta apontador os conduz a cabeça na
areia o foje persiste
não há muitas alternativas têm que
sobreviver ea realidade
realmente não pode fugir
então eu trabalho com os miúdos com
perturbações desenvolvimento são para
muitos deficientes nem és os autistas
os vídeos com deficiência intelectual e
uma série de exemplos que é impossível
disputar uma série de exemplos de
rótulos e que limitem são todos
diferentes e implementa pretendia que
tem mas tem toda uma coisa em comum tem
desde sempre e sempre uma desvantagem
pesquisa
claro que nesta margem nesta marcha ali
área tenha possibilidade de apontar as
suas incontáveis dos as suas e as duas
famílias já têm equipamentos pertencem e
em nossa sociedade criou e criou muito
vai e decretos e leis muito bem feitas
muito bem especificadas multiply citas
que abrangem esta população deficiente
miass esta pretensão aparenta estar
disposto a uma massa homogênea como são
as massas mas é uma não resposta para o
indivíduo porque são todos tão
diferentes têm todos escritos questões
individuais que encaixá los numa
engrenagem prefeita organizadora e
pintar um cenário falsa - escuro
esse é o cenário no qual eu acho que
trabalha com um cenário possa mensurar
esses algoritmos também pensados os 1200
crianças e jovens são orientados por
equipas multidisciplinares que a partida
terá um enorme conhecimento sobre os
seus problemas é ea sua patologia
após olhar minucioso dessas equipas era
de traçado um perfil de competências de
corresponder às suas respostas
capacidades de capacidades deste tipo de
competências tem que mexer um plano de
intervenção obviamente não encontramos o
problema sem pensar numa função
intervenção nestas vantagem faz toda a
diferença faz tanta diferença como
antibiótico uma infecção mas é uma
diferença que não é visível na sociedade
ou pelo menos não tão ofensiva mas
porque fazer diagnósticos em nossa
intervenção não foi o
nosso objetivo principal talvez seja
para ter um atestado de costa tem
capacidade seguramente esse não é o
nosso objetivo não é objetivo da equipe
em que eu trabalho
nós tomamos chineses e expande
intervenção na unidade hospitalar mas
claro que tudo era muito pouco tempo
porque os recursos são escassos e
concorrer podem calcular este tipo de
intervenção que é necessário neste
patologia vai durar muito tempo e vai
ter muitas necessidades nem querer antes
já volta a continuidade da intervenção a
conhecer melhor o hospital lado claro
que a comunidade é o destino óbvio mas
em lugar da comunidade é que tudo isto
vai continuar e nós devemos ter isto
muito bem definido o percurso vai pensar
num discurso seguro seguro para as
crianças e pais com eles porque ninguém
se perdesse com estações e apeadeiros e
sempre com os prefeitos a passar o
testemunho era e é isso que está pensado
na lei e na prática o que nós fazemos é
sugerir a todos
todos estes personagens que passa no
nosso que havia procurei no mapa procura
no mapa de curso nós fizemos a nossa
inscrição procurei no mapa sabendo nós
que esse mapa não é uma panacéia difícil
de ver
mas enfim queremos fundo cumprimos o
nosso papel nós sentimos que o conteúdo
se as famílias tiverem os discursos a
todos os níveis
enquanto eram bons técnicos terão
acompanhamento falo ficaram apaziguadas
se as famílias tiverem muito poucos
russos podem eventualmente denunciados
subsídios do estado
existe um subsídio da segurança social
se chama social de educação especial se
prende com as duas mãos se lados e que
as famílias precisam dos cursos técnicos
por ventos montante bastante ovários das
famílias têm que ter um nível econômico
repercute muito muito mais
mas ainda não sei se na área o que é
pena não ter custos muito baixos que não
pode usufruir disso é possível mas tem
recursos continuam a ser mais importante
não pode mandar não terá acompanhamento
há uma gota no estudo que assim off para
quem trabalha nisto é não há qualquer
continuidade em tempo eles quem escreve
finalizou
o plano fez um plano cuidado conhece
cada um
e quem escuta tanto papel o nosso papel
o meu papel enquanto ele atua nesta área
e um papel só não passa do papel é
cosmético como em tudo o que mexe que
fede constante
outro fato gerador em que a atenção é
que quem trabalha nesta área e falar em
meu nome e no nome da minha equipa tem a
possibilidade de cruzar diariamente com
imensas famílias foram brindados com a
sorte de ter o filho não foi feito
essa coisa do filho do prefeito até pode
ser inspiração para muitos livros e
filmes sem uma coisa assim tão forte que
eu acho que é difícil descrever
acho que só tem um filho não vai ter
tempo de serviço eu posso apenas
infelizmente incluído o que é isso ai é
fácil perceber o estado mostrar qual é a
melhor forma de diminuir as duas das
famílias é fazer com que se encontrem e
troca de experiências
experiências e informações lutas
provavelmente estragos mais resultados
qualquer catarse momentânea em um
consultório de psiquiatria e psicologia
sugiro às melhorias que se encontra na
sala de espera hospitalar não pode ser
um ato terapêutico é impensável
por outro lado ea gente procura é o que
se encontra em não tem qualquer
resultado não quando elas estão tão
concentradas nesta massa nesta marcha
solitária que se calhar em sorte
portanto é nosso papel de ensinos juntá
las
[Música]
isto é um conjunto de palavras e sim
mais ou menos um no centro e depois
pensar em se trabalhar isto eu poderia
olhar para isso assim como no velo foi
de fato está completamente organizado e
esse kit jogava nela e conseguia achar o
fio e eu acho que é isso puxar o fio que
eu considero a origem dos militares
então
um grande estudo a yoki assim vamos
tentar fazer alguma coisa na nossa
comunidade que permita continuar fora
das portas do hospital o trabalho que
nós fazemos vamos passar a nossa
mensagem para fora das portas do
hospital mas na comunidade são os
primeiros - o problema econômico é
sempre o problema é difícil sim mas
existem os mais para eu sei que existem
os mais porque eu sou escritora dos tais
possíveis que o estado paga eu sei que
existem mais
com isso eu tenho pensado é muito
simples de 15 especialistas foi em 2011
há cinco anos é muito simples
juntamos à saúde à segurança social a
câmara municipal com algum arrojo e não
damos um salto à universidade e fazemos
uma espécie de consórcio
aveiro tem a dimensão ótima pra fazer
isso
claro que não é nada assim tão simples o
nome de sky para criar obras a espero
sempre nuno gomes pinto da falta de
enquadramento total e é certo que eu
batia uma série portas destas
instituições ao longo destes anos e
nunca teve portas fechadas mas tive
sempre portas entreabertas as portas
entre roupas para identificar a porta
fazendo ficar à porta esperar não fazem
nem ir embora pra entrar
ao fim de algum tempo a perceber que
realmente estão pedindo entre os
interruptores manda sua utilidade em
ouvir nem sequer no fato de eles dizerem
que a idéia era brilhante assistência
que era uma ideia brilhante temas óbvia
é e descobri que era preciso encontrar
outro formato debater outras portas em
2015 para ser ouvida na direção da santa
casa da misericórdia vai
curiosamente com esse primeiro
interlocutor que não descrever obrigada
de foi a primeira vez que acreditem que
está a acontecer em novembro de 2015 no
estilo militar gem archer é verdade ano
schwenck quanto idéia enquanto projecto
enquanto compromisso da santa casa da
misericórdia da avaya foi feita uma
apresentação à comunidade aveirense que
as coisas começaram a acontecer em
excesso de vaidade e 7 sem financiamento
e 7 receber como todos sabem dançar mas
pensaram que do início de 2016
foram cobrados protocol ti entre a santa
casa da misericórdia da vaga na
universidade harvard centro hospitalar
pastor no que diz respeito a esse objeto
no início de 2015
a santa casa da misericórdia de aveiro
assumiu o risco de contratar alguns
técnicos que constituíssem uma equipa
com a constituição mínima para começar
eu acredito que a médio prazo nós vamos
ter um financiamento que garantam a
sustentabilidade sem que as famílias
podem devo stf é santa casa da
misericórdia dava eu devo isso aos
miúdos ea família esteve também a mim ea
minha família não pagadores
entretanto ao longo deste tempo vamos
conseguir juntar à já alguns pais porque
uma das idéias é nós temos um sítio para
acolher os pais temos um grupo piloto
pais têm em comum o facto de terem
filhos street na nossa equipa nos
conhecerem acreditar em nós e de
precisarem está a gente consiga vez mais
e conquistar cada vez mais capacitados
para esse trabalho que é óbvia que é de
estarem juntos e trocar idéias e trocar
informações úteis das dálias habilidade
é o mote é tá ferramentas reabilitar
crianças habilitar pais habilitar os
irmãos avós professoras têm carlos cruz
no caminho e claro que isto tem tudo
para dar certo
dassié ter certo eu acho que suplicar
para os concelhos à volta talvez seja
apenas a solução natural
obrigado
[Aplausos]